in the teaser for the upcoming Pixar
movie Cars 3 we see Lightning McQueen
get flipped into the air on the
racetrack sparks fly smoke billows from
the car it's not looking good for old
lightning but there is some good news he
just saved 15% or more on his car
insurance by switching to Geico
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the show where
crazy ideas supported by detailed
research always gets the checkered flag
now as many of you loyal theorists know
I love me some Pixar even if I do have a
strange way of showing it and by strange
way of showing it I mean ruining your
childhood memories of beloved characters
look I'm not the one who decided that
everybody in wall-e is a cannibal I just
pointed it out okay don't kill the
messenger and then liquify their body
and drink them as creepy future food but
never fear those of you who wish to have
your childhoods remain intact because
today's Pixar theory isn't gonna have
some deep dark twists or is it no it
isn't probably instead today we're
simply going to consider the world of
cars a world that looks just like our
own except that there's no people and
all the machines run themselves to catch
you up the first Cars movie gave us the
story of a young hotshot racecar named
lightning mcqueen who gets a shot at the
championship but then gives it up
because he realizes how important the
other people in his other cars in his
life really are the sequel was the next
obvious place that you take that concept
a complicated spy thriller about car
espionage and alternative fuel source
conspiracy theories because why not in
cars three looks like it's lining up to
be a comeback story we've got a trailer
which shows lightning and a catastrophic
crash and if this series keeps following
the trajectory of the rocky series the
third installment will be about our
heroes fight back up to the top and hey
if we're really lucky we'll get a fourth
one where McQueen races against a
Russian muscle car and solves communism
sure you left that that sounds
ridiculous but I bet you didn't expect
the spy thriller plot either long story
short the cars universe has always been
a weird one filled with a lot of
questions about the logistics of a world
filled only with sentient automobiles
but one question none of us have ever
really stopped to answer is this are the
cars in cars really cars I mean sure
it's the title of the movie and they
look and behave like cars but who knows
it just may be more of mainstream
media's fake news
I need they have eyes and tongues and
there are no drivers and let's be honest
how did a society of living cars even
come to be in the first place they're
clearly on earth but there are no humans
so what happened
what are these creatures I am a hundred
percent confident I figured it out and
spoiler alert they're not cars what
started out as a simple stupid question
led me down the rabbit hole of this
bizarre car themed universe and the
answers I found will upend everything
you thought you knew about mater in the
gang and the details I find here posed
some really interesting revelations
about that infamous Pixar theory a
theory that you all have wanted me to
cover for quite a long time so theorists
start your search and because it's time
to take this cars
Amna theory from zero to sixty in about
15 minutes lat
now to begin it proudly merits taking a
second to acquaint you with that Pixar
theory a theory that started with as far
as I can tell
online movie blogger John Negroni which
aims to unite all the Pixar movies into
not just the same universe but also come
up with a cohesive timeline of events
where one movie leads to the next leads
to the next
suck on that Marvel here's everyone
thinking you started the whole huge
connected Cinematic Universe thing but
Pixar's been doing it back since 1995 in
a theoretical sense so no wonder you
don't have an Oscar award yet and yet
Academy Award winning Suicide Squad does
oh no I'm not gonna dive into the Nitty
Gritty of that theory today it's one
that will probably be piecing together
on our own across multiple future Pixar
episodes but to get a taste of this
thing and start you thinking about it
take the example of by and large most
casual pics our viewers know it as the
corporation that runs everything in
Walley world leadership we have
one button em to thank for the
cannibalistic cupcake in a cop but for
really astute viewers you can actually
see the company's rise to power
throughout multiple other Pixar films in
Toy Story 3 you can see their logo on
Buzz's battery by the time you get to up
by and large is now involved in the
construction business but their logo on
the equipment in front of Carl's house
and it's not just the equipment BNL is
also buying all the houses and Carl's
neighborhood it's even spreading to the
Cars franchise now if you examine the
Cars 3 extended trailer frame by frame
you see the logo appear in the stadium
making it the first time buy and learn
disappeared anywhere in the Cars movie
series did you spot it here let me slow
it down for you still now here let's go
frame by frame welcome to my life
writing theories I live my life a
quarter frame at a time
no the reason I wanted to start talking
about this today is because I have a few
problems with the Pixar theory timeline
and the first major batch revolves
around cars the theory goes that a super
intelligent AI first created by Syndrome
in his quest to kill all the superheroes
back in The Incredibles forms BNL to
take control of the planets along the
way intelligent animals like the ones
that we see in Finding Nemo and
ratatouille who rise up against humans a
war ensues animals are killed off and
the AI acting through by and large send
humans into space
thus kicking off wall-e and leaving the
planet alone to the AI the AI to get a
life of freedom on their newly conquered
planet by assuming the form of sentient
cars planes boats and graves cuz
seriously think about the coolest way to
get around that's why you don't see
humans or animals in either car movie
and yet see the remnants of human
society like the Eiffel Tower route 66
and things like that oh man you got all
that being a part in piecing together
this whole theory in detail is gonna be
like this channel's equivalent to the
math well no time like the present carpe
that diem let's
art today so this whole Pixar theory is
an interesting explanation but there are
a lot of assumptions assumptions that
when you actually stop to look at the
deeper evidence just don't work out and
the first set of assumptions that I want
to tackle today has to do with the
nature of the cars you see based on the
theory as it exists the cars would be
basically smart driverless cars taken
over by syndromes super advanced AI they
would be cars machines with computers in
them controlled by an AI except they're
knobs the cars are actually organic
creatures living creatures with a car
body as a tough exoskeleton but
containing some sort of internal organs
a soft and squishy inside like the
center of a Tootsie Roll pop you could
almost equate them to that terrible
monster truck movie that no one bothered
to see by the way it's worth mentioning
that thing cost a hundred and twenty
five million dollars to make and only
earned back sixty million makes you
almost feel bad for them almost anyway
back to the good car movies we know that
the cars are living from a bunch of
different evidence sprinkled throughout
the various car features first they
breathe oxygen in the opening of cars
too we see super spy Finn McMissile put
on an underwater respirator in order to
swim out of sight of the criminal
syndicate later in that same movie we
see plenty of scenes of cars eating and
drinking on the plane to Japan we see
snack foods littered around the floor
things like chips and sushi and again at
the party more sushi at the bar
and of course the infamous pistachio ice
cream bits combat catfish - a scene that
tells us mater knows what pistachios are
what ice cream is and has tested it and
enjoyed it
and sure we see them drinking varieties
of oil and gas presumably to power their
engines but why would they actually need
to ingest food products if they were
organic in some way even some of the
offshoot cartoons support the idea of
the cars being organic creatures in the
first hails from Radiator Springs short
we see lightning
queen getting a case of the hiccups
hiccups are caused by irritating the
diaphragm dome-shaped muscle at the
bottom of your chest when you do things
like eat or drink too quickly it upsets
the diaphragm and causes it to pull down
in a jerky way yes uh Karen D our throat
suddenly your vocal cords closed
abruptly and you're left with a hiccup
all of this evidence from the underwater
breathing to the food to the hiccups
implies that under the hood of the cars
both literally and figuratively they
possess internal organs like lungs
stomachs and diaphragms in addition to
their car engines but perhaps the
biggest confirmation comes from the
animators themselves in most interviews
the Pixar crew tends to be dismissive of
biological questions as they relate to
the cars but one featurette released on
the official Disney Pixar channel
entitled Pixar studios stories gave us
all of the confirmation that we needed
he can't open his doors because that's
where his brains are they have a brain a
giant pink pulsating brain hidden behind
those car windows it's just disturbing
try getting that out of your head the
next time you see a Cars movie bring out
the brain bleach that the cars are
actual living creatures and not just
some highly advanced driverless cars and
before you complain about how stupid
that all sounds there's an actual
evolutionary change present throughout
these films at about 50 minutes and 10
seconds into cars - as if watching
nearly an hour of a kid's movie
featuring cars in Japan busting a fake
eco-friendly Fuel ring and a massive
James Bond riff wasn't bizarre enough we
see birds except they're not Birds
they're actually mini plays think that
was just because the Pixar team was off
their meds for what seems like the
entirety of this movie well think again
because in another of the tales from
Radiator Springs animated shorts you
actually get VW beetle beetle
tiny cars with insect wings that make up
this disturbing universes bug population
thus proving that the Pixar team is off
their meds
literally all the time or on something
else now this is an important detail
because it shows us that in this
universe these Karluk creatures don't
just become planes when they fly like
the birds but rather they can develop
organic wings like those of a dragonfly
and all
this is without even mentioning the fact
that there exist alien car-like species
as we see in mater's tall tales UFO
Edition which we know is true since
Mader shows that you can in fact fly in
the end of the episode as one final
detail it's interesting to note that the
rubber tires aren't part of these car
creatures in multiple parts of the
series but most notably cartoons train
scene we see characters moving around
with their tires removed they're the
equivalent of shoes for the cars going
on the feet or in this case rims suffice
it to say alien or no these are living
creatures with internal organs that are
protected by a car like exoskeleton and
with multiple differentiated animal-like
species that have evolved over time from
literal boats planes and cranes to
bug-like and bird-like animals in short
when you look at all of this evidence
there is only one possible conclusion
that the cars in cars aren't cars at all
but are much more likely a highly
evolved form of insect sounds ridiculous
but think about it just like an insect
has a hard exoskeleton made of chitin
that the creatures in the Carver's have
evolved a stronger exoskeleton made of
various metals neither cars nor insects
seem to possess an internal skeleton and
so in both creatures muscles appear to
be directly attached to the exoskeleton
itself an insect's exoskeleton isn't a
single surface but rather consists of
multiple jointed plates so that when an
insect moves a muscle it causes the
connected exoskeleton plate pieces to
move as well it's the same style of
movement that we see in the cards
multiple hard plates are shells moving
when the internal musculature moves as
well but most importantly of all in the
piece of evidence that solidifies this
is as we saw with the VW Beetle example
some species of the cars are able to
grow wings that aren't made of metal
instead based on the appearance and
behavior of those wings they're made of
chitin just like the wings of a
dragonfly the same substance that makes
up an insect's exoskeleton those chitin
based wings are remnant from the car's
evolutionary ancestors the cars in cars
aren't cars there
sex and that does some really
interesting things for the Pixar theory
first and foremost it removes cars from
being attached to the arrow of humans
that sort of evolution is going to take
a really long time so get it away from
the Wally's Nemo's and Incredibles of
the world and put it out toward the
future but surprisingly enough we do
happen to have one film in Pixar's
lineup that does follow super
intelligent bugs in their quest for
survival bugs that already have figured
out ways to master machine bugs that
live in a world where there are remnants
of human society but you see no humans
presents yes what I propose to you is
that cars isn't so much its own entity
but rather a bug's life two three and
coming up on four the natural
progression of insects evolving and
taking over the planet er and with that
we have the first puzzle pieces in place
as we all start to build our own film
theorists approved mega Pixar theory but
for now remember it's just a theory of
film theory and cuts are you as excited
as I am this is my first toe dipped into
the Pixar theory pool and already were
coming up with some huge revelations so
if you want to unravel the mysteries of
the Pixar universe with me make sure you
subscribe to the channel by slapping the
film Theory logo smack dab in the middle
of the screen and hey after you've done
that check out my past theory on wall-e
cannibalism or for something lighter
just let it go and watch this one I'm
frozen now if you all excuse me I got to
go work on a Logan theory because
everything goes according to plan that
one's happening next week